you
well she's silly was curious she wasn't
professionally curious a lot of
interviews and I'm not including you but
a lot of interviews have a job to do and
they have to interview somebody it's a
movie star or some very successful
political figure however and they have a
job to do and they have their questions
and they go about it my mother was
curious as as any Mike Wallace or any
you know Charlie Rose or anybody curious
but her purpose wasn't professional her
purpose was to see how these more
assimilated Americans were were in body
and spirit and she wanted to learn about
the larger life than was possible from
her insular background as an Italian
immigrant as a woman of Italian
background you see the immigration to
Italy brought with it people who didn't
speak the language I told you this
before my mother's mother and father
couldn't even speak English they lived
in Brooklyn but they couldn't even speak
English their whole lives my brother had
to take Italian lessons to speak to her
mother father and so this sense of being
isolated being different being foreign
being foreign my mother at her dress
shop was able to feel in the company of
women whom she knew well because they
were regular customers they were not 26
years old they were 56 years old they
were middle-aged women rather portly my
mother specialized in large size dresses
and large size suits for mature women
and women who were very gently reared
and had time on their hands and they
would come in on middle the afternoon
and they would not only go through the
clothing that was on the racks but they
would talk and they would just it was
like it was like a talk show in a way
and the women were just rhapsodizing or
just commenting or recalling things
about their daily lives or maybe about
their families or maybe about something
of the atmosphere of the town in this
war time period that my mother found
very interesting and very instructive
and see was she was like going to school
on these women she was learning through
but through a very interesting way of
questioning she was never aggressive and
she never interrupted people started
talking and she wouldn't change the
subject she would she would patiently
listen and out of this patients came the
uninterruptedly monologues I should say
that were that were like the like this
story like like a like a like a verbal
si out of these women's mouths and these
women again were not people that were
newsworthy these women when they died
probably got a little obituary but not
much they were not what you would call
today women of any achievement but they
were women who echoed the character of
the town they were the spine of the
moral virtuous of the town they were may
be skeptical of certain trends at that
time they were it may be critical but
they gave voice to a whole sense of
small-town stability and my mother just
was very yeah on the intake of this
these kind of women and so was I who
listened in the background so this was a
very great experience for me and later
on useful to me when I too became an
interview were granted a professional
one but I had a way of not interrupting
letting people tell their stories in my
mission I always thought was to give
voice to other people by listening well
and writing from their point of view not
mine their point of view what it is that
they represented
well um if we were talking about what
most of your audience would be familiar
with I guess Charlie Rose within you
know within the limitations of his time
but he is as good as you get on
television granted every day is talking
to someone new and it's within the
limitations of maybe a half hour an hour
i'm not sure um he he doesn't erupt a
lot as people who are critical of him
I'm not critical of him I think he does
a very good job what I most like about
him is he he does allow people's point
of view different than his own in many
cases to give full vent to it he allows
people to talk and he also was a
gentleman that's one thing I think that
journalists should be that are not he is
a gentleman he has well mannered that's
why people go on his show because they
feel they're not being abused and the
old days of Mike Wallace one long before
your lifetime he was very abusive tough
he was like a detective in the
prosecutorial mentality the old Mike
Wallace on night beat and even to agree
60 minutes um I think Chris Matthews
some people who work in not an
interviewer he's really more of a of a
ranter but he's amusing but I think in
print media I'll tell you the truth in
the magazine business today and the
newspaper business there's not much that
I find arm admirable but i think it's
not necessarily the fault of a
particular group of individuals as
journalists space is not afforded to
such people the technology is ruined it
I mean I believe the invention of the
tape recorder was one of the most
disastrous inventions in terms of what
I'm speaking about because I said to you
before that it's so important to let
people say what they want to say and
have a sense of what who they are rather
than what they say I'm not looking for
in my own work as a as a
person the words out of people's mouths
I want to feel I know the people and I
can describe them when you when you when
the taper or tape recorder came into
prominence maybe in the 1960s first I
never had one I still never have a tape
recorder I never used one of my life mmm
but um but I think what's wrong with the
tape recorder it turned the whole art of
the interview the hanging out the art of
hanging out which is the way I put it it
made it a question and answer qat qat
and sometimes you see even the New York
Times Magazine on other magazines use
the Q&A and what's that what that has
done is give to the person who's being
interviewed the verbatim control over
the interview and the person is
conducting the interview is really just
not a reporter but a recorder with a
little tape going around and it also
brought the interview which I always
thought as a grand experience sometimes
the outdoors with the whole descriptive
frame around the story and the person
within the story the persons within the
story it brought it into the interior
world of them of a room most of these
Q&A with the tape recorder are in a room
so it it brought the interviewer indoors
and I think more narrowly confined than
when I was a practicing writer of this
form beginning in the 1960s after i left
the new york times and start working
life for Esquire and also now as i'm in
my very very very senior years i see the
world even more defined narrowly by the
excessive use of laptops people are
sitting all day indoors looking at a
laptop and i get information they're
going to push some keyboard everybody
has a keyboard now in their heads when
my when I was in my 20s the only people
had keyboards were journalists like me
and type it's women usually typist now
every guy I mean fat kid in every little
kid they all you know and what are they
doing they're googling the through their
lives they're getting information from
within this and they're sitting there no
wonder they're so fat I mean the whole
fatf are the reasons the junk food
parties little laptop and this society
isn't reaching out and this society has
become so goal oriented so linear it is
like they want information they put in
the buttons in a google it and they get
what they want to get well they do get
what what they miss is what they didn't
want to get but what they discovered
there isn't any sense of serendipity
they don't just I uses wander around I
never never knew exactly what I was
looking for I knew vaguely what I hoped
to find or had some rough idea but I was
in the exploratory mode all the time
from time I was young to time I'm
practically senile on the subject but I
always believe that you're not you don't
you don't you can't be so goal-oriented
I just go ahead and discover it you'll
find by chance by accident some terrific
stories some terrific people you never
thought you would meet this is what I
don't think is going on anymore because
in a narrowly define world of laptop
people laughing it up on the laptop well
I'm glad I'm getting out of here
you